-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
and Tony Award-winning actor
you know from shows
such as "Schmigadoon!"
and "The Good Wife."
He is currently starring
in "Burn,"
which is playing at
the Joyce theater.
And he also starred in the final
season of "The Good Fight."
New episodes stream Thursdays
on Paramount+.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Alan Cumming,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Look at how monochromatic
we both are.
-I know, right?
-It's very lovely.
-And it's -- it's the first day
of autumn,
so I'm going for a cozy look.
-It's very cozy.
You look very cozy.
-Thanks.
-So, this is --
you're doing a one-man show
right now,
which historically are known
to be exhausting
for the people on stage.
-Oh, do you think?
-You've got to do it all
yourself.
-Yes.
-And there's an element
of dance?
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-You've done this to yourself,
as well, we should note.
-And it was my idea.
I have no one to blame.
So, I mean,
I'm nearly finished it.
And it's sort of -- I mean, you
just hurt when you're dancing.
You just hurt.
Things -- right now,
I'm hurting in front of you.
-[ Laughs ]
-And it's --
I know. You know, and also,
I'm getting older.
I'm not -- I shouldn't be --
like, this is sort
of my dance theater debut at 57.
[ Laughter ]
I know, it's hard to believe.
-Very few people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know. I know.
-Very few people break into
the stage dance game that late.
-It's just mental.
And so, I have had -- you know,
I wake up and I'm like,
"Oh, ouch,"
and funny things happen.
And just -- I've got sore arms.
I don't know why.
-Do you do a lot of arm movement
during you're dancing?
-I guess I must do it.
And then I bang myself on the
table, and I have to jump.
It's just a lot of stuff
going on.
-Now, the other interesting
thing about having
all this element of movement,
is it is a one-man show
about a Scottish poet,
Robert Burns.
I think if you heard there
was a one-man show
about a Scottish poet,
you might not think
there'd be that much dancing.
-You'd think there might
be poetry.
-Yeah.
-Well, there's a little bit
of poetry.
I mean, I speak in it as well.
But I sort of -- like, what I
wanted to do with this show,
because Robert Burns
is this huge icon in Scotland.
He's our national bard.
And I wanted -- I found out lots
of things about him
that were really surprising
to me.
About the fact that he was
bipolar and he had this --
you know, was much more fragile
and had this terrible life.
And so, I'm asking -- I'm asking
the audience to sort of think,
especially in Scotland, where we
did it first, to think again,
about someone that you have all
these preconceived ideas about.
So, I thought, in a way,
if I did that in a form
that was not something they were
used to seeing me doing,
then that would sort of help.
So the dance thing kind of helps
you break down your barriers
and receive new information.
Because you're so like,
"What the [bleep] is going on?
Alan Cumming's dancing."
-I -- well, I also heard
to prepare for this role,
because it was physically
and emotionally taxing,
that you stopped drinking
for a while.
How did that go?
[ Laughter ]
-I think your research is a
little lacking, sorry to say,
but --
[ Laughter ]
-You went one evening?
-It was about two nights,
I think, I might --
[ Laughter ]
-Two nights?!
-Because then I'd --
I honestly thought, and then
when I came home and I was like,
"Ow, oh, oh."
I went, "Oh, I'm not allowed --
Oh, [bleep] that,
I'm going to have a drink."
Sorry, I keep swearing.
-I think the problem
you should worry about
is that you stopped
drinking for two days
and it was such news that it
made it to our research team.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody was walking
around Broadway being like,
"Did you hear about Alan?"
-"What?!
Alan Cumming stopped drinking?"
-"48 hours."
-"I know. Is he all right?"
Like, that's terrible.
Yeah, no, I think I had to --
you know, you have to --
I mean, I've lost weight,
and my body is doing
all these things, and it's been
an incredible experience.
And you know, I've got these
funny hair extensions.
My nails are black.
There's a whole new vibe
I'm going for with this,
but the one constant
was vodka soda,
just to get me through
the thing.
-Yeah, that's good.
We appreciate your honesty.
-Yeah.
You know, obviously,
I don't need to tell you
because it was well-covered --
the Queen recently passed away.
-What?!
-And yeah -- Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that how deep you've
been in your one-man show?
[ Laughter ]
-I've been in a "Burn" cave.
-Did you -- a lot of people
have been sharing anecdotes
about meeting the Queen,
crossing paths.
Did you ever -- did you ever
have the pleasure?
-I never properly met her.
I met a lot of them.
Like, I met Prince Charles when
I did that film "Golden Eye,"
the James Bond one.
He was --
It was the Royal premiere night,
and you get all these pages
of etiquette for things.
And I was standing next
to Judi Dench,
and I said "I'm not bowing.
I'm not bowing. Are you bowing?"
And she was like, "I have
to bow. I'm a dame."
I was like, "Oh, all right."
And then, but it said --
But on the the etiquette,
it said men must bow
from the neck forward.
I was like, "Well, you're hardly
going to bow
from the neck back."
[ Laughter ]
So -- We -- It was --
-Like a Pez dispenser.
-Yes.
And so, on the news there was
like, there's Prince Charles
and Pierce Brosnan,
and in the background,
you see me and Judi Dench
laughing and going like this --
[ Laughter ]
-But I -- one time when I was
in the Scouts,
like the Boy Scouts,
and we were --
-So, this is when you were
younger?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Imagine if I was still
in the Scouts now.
That would be hilarious.
Where's I'm hiking, you know,
I'm orienteering or something in
Deeside in Aberdeenshire,
which is near Balmoral,
and so it was raining
and we were lost.
And I was, like,
the patrol leader.
And I said,
"Oh, I can't deal with this.
It's not my forte."
And so, we saw this Land Rover
coming along this little track,
and I said,
"Well, let's just hitch a lift.
They'll take pity on us.
We're all bedraggled
and wet-looking scouts."
It was the Queen
in a Land Rover,
and she didn't blooming well
stop.
[ Laughter ]
We were like...
We were like, "Oh,
it's the Queen. Hi!"
[ Laughter ]
So, that is my claim to fame,
that the Queen did not
pick me up.
-All right. Well, thank you
for sharing a story,
because I feel like right now,
maybe a lot of the stories
are inflating her kindness,
and it's nice to get --
-Balance.
-Yeah, get a little balance.
-Balance is everything.
-I have more to ask you.
We'll be right back with
Alan Cumming, everybody.